give them the skills imagine going to
college where you would learn the skills
of how to be a functional person where
you would learn an honest assessment of
History where you might learn some basic
economics the tools then to go out into
the world as a 21 year old let's say and
have some basic knowledge of how to
function in in the society wouldn't that
be good rather than learning lesbian
badminton it probably would but listen
to how the mainstream media treats
Florida and governor governor DeSantis
as he's going ahead and doing these
things here is Don Lemon from CNN Layla
thank you this is thank you probably
this is bizarre I know
I know what are we doing here I mean
this I feel like we're going back I feel
like I'm watching a bad version of like
Pleasantville where you're I I don't get
what's happening it feels like the 1950s
all over again with like book Banning
this is this is cancel culture from
people who are I guess they just want
our kids to be ignorant and to control
the teachers it is
this is outrageous I I don't I really
don't even know how to explain what's
going on here it's just Don Lemon is a
complete and utter buffoon
propagandist liar he either has no idea
what he's talking about in which case he
should be fired and that's not cancel
culture you are you should be fired when
you are completely incompetent at what
you do right if you dig holes for pools
and you can't do that right you should
be fired if you whatever it is that you
do if you don't do it well you should be
fired that's not cancel culture so he
either has no idea what he's talking
about or he is a complete liar and and
propagandist the book that he's
referring to is a book called
genderqueer which was going into
elementary schools we're talking about
second and third grade it was literally
showing body parts and talking to kids
about how to give hand jobs so if you
think that should be in schools then you
should be hanging out with Don lemon
that is what they were Banning nobody
thinks it should be there and no one's
Banning the books as if the books can't
be published but they should not be in
public schools we all know that but
that's why they never mention the title
of the book or the content of the book
he just tries to make it like it's
hysteria and this is book burning as if
it's 1934 Nazi Germany it's completely
insane
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]